The kids are officially home for the summer,
and since we're homeschooling next year,
that means they're gonna be home for every day after that, too!
And since it's been a while since I've done a basic makeup tutorial,
I decided today was a good day for it!
My new favorite foundation is that YSL.
It's absolutely incredible.
I did contour and highlight with the Fenty Matchstick in amber
and born this way concealer in porcelain.
The NYX Fluff and fill is my go to eyebrow pencil,
and after setting all of it,
I go in with just a neutral
taupe color from the Too Faced natural palette.
This has been my go to makeup look forever.
And if you see me in a video,
i'm usually wearing this look,
adding a little dark shade to the outer corner
and buffing that out so it's nice and smooth.
And then for my liner,
I always use kat von d's tattoo liner and a drugstore favorite,
l'oreal's voluminous mascara.
Little shimmer in the corner of the eye really makes a difference.
And then as my curls sit,
I use a Milani cheek stain and Charlotte Tilbury
amazing Amal on the lips. This look always makes me feel like me.
It is classic and easy because somehow
my day always goes smoother when I'm ready for the day.